the headline is roe versus wade is dead
but is that true well that is mostly the
case but the reality of this particular
situation is so much worse than that
headline makes it seem and i'm not
talking about that from a political
standpoint of the idea that the
constitutional enshrinement of a woman's
right to choose may be dead in america
but rather the procedural machinations
of what happened in this particular case
are bad for the rule of law it creates
uncertainty and it hurts the legitimacy
of the supreme court regardless of where
you fall on the political spectrum the
outcome in this case is not good for
anyone because in the dead of night
without any judge signing the decision
five conservative justices on the
supreme court overruled the right to
abortion allowing a texas law banning
all abortions after six weeks to go into
effect with no exceptions for rape or
incest and to accomplish this the five
justice majority acquiesce to a
procedural trick dreamed up by the texas
legislature explicitly for the purpose
of evading federal judicial review this
isn't the way that any cases are
supposed to be decided let alone one of
the most important cases that has ever
come before the supreme court
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a constitutional scholar because in 1973
roe vs wade challenged a texas law that
criminalized helping a woman get an
abortion the supreme court ruled that
the law was unconstitutional that women
had a right to an abortion during their
first trimester 48 years later in 2021
texas passed a new bill that outlawed
abortion after six weeks a clear
violation of roe and the subsequent
casey versus planned parenthood case
rather than criminalizing abortion this
time texas gave private citizens the
right to sue anyone who aids a person in
getting an abortion giving them a chance
to win ten thousand dollars if they were
willing to knark on the better the law
also created a procedural rube goldberg
machine meant to deny anyone the right
to challenge that law in federal court
so what did the supreme court do on
wednesday night did they overrule roe vs
waden's progeny without doing so
explicitly and what happens to all of
the women who are stuck in the middle in
texas
well it's time to find out so let's talk
about a summary of how the supreme court
got to what is still technically the law
of the land today and how the supreme
court found a right of privacy which
then led to a woman's right to choose
now as we've covered on this channel in
the past the right to privacy is not
specifically mentioned in the u.s
constitution but according to still
technically current jurisprudence from
the supreme court
they have found that that right to
privacy is implied by several amendments
the first amendment allows a person to
choose any religious belief and to keep
their choice private the fourth
amendment protects against unreasonable
violations of privacy government
searches and seizures the third
amendment establishes a zone of privacy
in a person's home the fifth amendment
creates a right against
self-incrimination which therefore
protects someone's private information
the ninth amendment says that the
enumeration of the constitution of a
certain right shall not be construed to
deny or disparage other rights retained
by the people courts have interpreted
this as allowing for broad protections
of privacy rights in ways not
specifically listed in the first eight
amendments and the 14th amendment
prohibits states for making laws that
infringe upon a person's autonomy
protections provided for in the first 13
amendments without this right to privacy
states would be allowed to prohibit
married couples from using contraception
it would criminalize certain kinds of
intimate sexual contact between
consenting adults it would ban teenagers
from using birth control and it would
outlaw abortion because before the
supreme court's decision in griswold vs
connecticut it was legal for states to
ban all of that behavior now abortion
rights in the us are controlled
generally by two cases roe vs wade and
planned parenthood versus casey this is
a very very brief summary but roe struck
down a texas law that criminalized
aiding a woman in getting an abortion
the supreme court ruled that this was a
violation the due process claused the
14th amendment because it violated a
woman's fundamental right to privacy
first trimester abortion became legal
for any reason and abortions in the
second and third trimesters were
restricted unless certain conditions
like risk the mother's life were met now
in 1992 when planned parenthood vs casey
the court more or less reaffirmed the
holding of roe that women had a right to
a safe and legal abortion but altered
the standard for analyzing the
restrictions to that right the court
overturned the trimester framework
entirely in favor of a viability
analysis the court's decision also
replaced the strict scrutiny standard of
review required by roe with the undue
burden standard under which abortion
restrictions were unconstitutional when
they were enacted quote for the purpose
or effect of placing a substantial
obstacle in the path of a woman seeking
an abortion of a non-viable fetus
crucially before viability casey says
the state's interests are not sufficient
to interfere with a woman's right to
choose which takes us to this current
texas heartbeat bill here at issue is
texas senate bill 8 which effectively
makes abortion illegal after six weeks
with no exceptions for anything
including rape or incest and it doesn't
even take viability into account this
plainly contravenes the holdings of roe
and casey the legislature admits that
this is exactly what they intended to do
asserting that there is no obligation to
follow federal law quote the legislature
finds that the state of texas never
repealed either expressly or by
implication the state statutes enacted
before the ruling in roe versus wade
that prohibit and criminalize abortion
unless a mother's life is in danger
under sb-8 any texas resident can sue a
person for abetting an abortion and
collect a minimum of ten thousand
dollars plus attorney's fees section
171.208 b lists the remedies permitted
by this new cause of action for these
private attorneys general if a claimant
prevails in an action brought under this
section the court shall award injunctive
relief sufficient to prevent the
defendant from violating this
sub-chapter or engaging in acts that aid
or bet violations of this sub-chapter
two statutory damage is an amount not
less than ten thousand dollars for each
abortion that the defendant performed or
induced in violation of this sub-chapter
and for each abortion performed or
induced in violation of the sub-chapter
that the defendant aided and abetted and
three costs and attorney's fees and that
last one cost and attorney's fees is one
way only successful plaintiffs are
entitled to costs and attorneys fees
successful defendants are not it is a
one-way fee shifting provision now this
law was written very strategically it
doesn't allow private bounty hunters to
sue the women but it's written very
broadly so that anyone who helps a
pregnant person could be sued anyone who
pays for or reimburses the cost of an
abortion through insurance or otherwise
can be in a better this means a person's
friends family doctor counselor minister
could be sued this could be an uber
driver or a person who contributes funds
for an abortion this is also of course
an attack on employees of abortion
clinics since anyone who works there is
liable if they defy this law and help
induce an abortion to occur in the event
a person successfully sues an abortion
provider the court must permanently shut
it down and if the defendant in one of
these cases actually prevails they're
not permitted to seek attorney's fees
from the other side only the plaintiffs
are as justice sotomayar explained in
her dissent the law deputizes the state
citizens as bounty hunters offering them
cash prizes for civilly prosecuting
their neighbor's medical procedures so
there are obviously plenty of things
about sb-8 that we would ordinarily
expect to be struck down in court after
a full hearing on the merits of the law
it's clearly in violation of planned
parenthood versus casey but that's not
what the supreme court did here instead
they took advantage of a kafka-esque
procedure created by the texas
legislature the supreme court's 1908
decision in ex parte young established
that someone raising a constitutional
challenge to a state law can sue the
state officer charged with enforcing
that law so usually when a state passes
an anti-abortion law abortion providers
file a pre-enforcement suit against the
state officials in federal court
challenging its constitutionality they
are allowed to file this suit because if
an unconstitutional law goes into effect
it will immediately curtail individual
rights and when a district court grants
a preliminary injunction the law never
actually goes into effect this has
happened repeatedly over the decades
frustrating conservative attempts to
overturn roe so how did the texas law
get around federal court deference to
roe well it eliminated the state
officials from the equation so that
there aren't any state officials who can
be sued the law states quote the
requirement of the subchapter shall be
enforced exclusively through private
civil actions the law can be enforced by
anyone who is against abortion but it
can't be enforced by state or local
officials meanwhile abortion clinics
can't sue the state of texas because no
state official has the power to enforce
this law and if a court entered an
injunction against the enforcement of
the law
the argument is that it would be null
because state officials have nothing to
do with enforcing this law the texas
attorney general and other state
officials can't enforce this law so
theoretically they can't be sued other
common targets can't be sued either the
governor has no power to enforce the law
so he can't be sued you can't sue the
texas legislature because they have
legislative immunity so the only
litigants who can challenge sb8 are
people and organizations who are
actually sued in civil court but it's
not clear whether a person who is sued
can actually say that the law is
unconstitutional that's because section
171.208 e eliminates several defenses
one ignorance or mistake of the law two
defendants believe that the requirements
of this subchapter are unconstitutional
or were unconstitutional
three a defense reliance on any court
decision that has been overruled on
appeal or by subsequent court even that
court decision had not been overruled
when the defendant engaged in conduct
that violates the subchapter
for defendant's reliance on any state or
federal court decision there's not
binding on this court in which the
action has been brought five non-mutual
issue preclusion or non-mutual claim
preclusion the sixth the consent of the
unborn child's mother to the abortion
and seven any claim that the enforcement
of the sub-chapter or the imposition of
civil liability against the defendant
will violate the constitutional rights
of third parties except as provided by
171.209 and section
171.209 expressly denies third-party
standing in state court texas has argued
that since a pregnant woman can't be
sued a pregnant person lacks standing to
challenge the law and under this law
pregnant women are deprived of any
agency and a third party like an
insurance company abortion rights group
also cannot invoke the constitutional
rights of a third party unless the
supreme court gives them standing and
note that this law is specifically
taking aim at the current extant
jurisprudence on the supreme court and
says that if roe or casey is overturned
by the supreme court
you weren't allowed to rely on the
supreme court jurisprudence because it
was later overturned so there's
absolutely no doubt whatsoever that this
law was written specifically with an
intent towards avoiding federal
oversight it's
sort of evil genius in that respect and
normally that wouldn't necessarily be an
issue but the supreme court as we'll
talk about in just a minute has
acquiesced to the gamesmanship of this
particular bill in a way that
i don't think i've ever seen before but
let's talk about the procedural history
of what happened when this law was
passed because that raises questions too
texas governor greg abbott signed the
texas law on may 19 2021 the law is
known as a heartbeat bill which bans
doctors from performing abortions once
they can detect a fetal heartbeat around
the sixth week of pregnancy over 15
states have enacted heartbeat bills and
federal courts have struck down each one
because they violate the right to an
abortion established by row and casey
and despite their unconstitutionality
legislatures keep passing the bills
texas added these unique provisions to
the new law which allow private citizens
to collect civil bounties for snitching
on anyone that abets an abortion as an
aside there are many laws like these on
the books they're called private
attorney general laws where someone who
isn't personally affected by the law can
sue on someone else's behalf if there is
indeed a violation of the law generally
it has been democratic legislators that
have passed private attorneys general's
law because they allow
individuals to enforce the law against
generally large corporations and you
often see this in a class context where
there's small violations that you
aggregate on behalf of a class of people
and often it was
generally conservative
executives that railed against these
particular laws these were the kinds of
things that president reagan railed
against saying that really the only
people that made money were the trial
lawyers and that we needed things like
tort reform so if nothing else it is
perhaps ironic that the texas
legislature has adopted this particular
tool now in july 2021 texas abortion
providers sued to enjoin the law before
it became effective on september 1st
since the providers can't sue state
officials and the legislature has
immunity from suit the providers sued
the court personnel who are responsible
for enforcing the law a state judge and
a county court clerk they also sued mark
dixon an anti-abortion activist who
plaintiffs assume would be one of the
first people to file lawsuits to collect
the bounties now that's generally a
no-no because courts are not in the
business of offering prospective
opinions and the court clerk judge and
activist filed a motion to dismiss but
the federal district court judge pittman
presided and denied the motion on august
25th allowing the suit to go forward the
federal court agreed with plaintiffs
that the defense would in fact play a
role in enforcing the statutes either by
filing a lawsuit or by adjudicating them
the defendants quickly filed an appeal
on the motion to dismiss with the 5th
circuit the court of appeals that hears
the
appeals from the district court the
defendants also wanted the appeals court
to halt other proceedings in the
district court including a hearing on
the challenger's request for preliminary
injunction that was scheduled for august
30th now up until this point this was a
fairly standard trip to the court of
appeals in a pre-enforcement action
however this is where the normal process
ended the fifth circuit granted the
defendant's request it canceled the
upcoming hearing and granted the motion
to stop the district court proceedings
and then denied the plaintiff's request
to expedite the appeal so in other words
the fifth circuit stopped the district
court from stopping the law from going
into effect and the fifth circuit
declined to explain the basis for its
ruling so the plaintiffs had to appeal
directly to the supreme court for an
injunction in joining the law from going
into effect while the legal case wound
its way through the courts for a merits
decision remember at this point no
marriage decision has been decided a
full decision on sb-8 would normally
take years to resolve by
the district court the court of appeals
of the fifth circuit and then the
supreme court so with this request in
front of the supreme court under this
procedure the emergency motion first
went to justice alito who was assigned
to hear emergency requests from texas
alito had the right to act on his own or
refer to the full court and he chose to
refer it to the full supreme court there
one day after the law went into effect a
five justice majority ruled that there
was no harm that justified in
emergencies say the unsigned order from
the supreme court stated that it was
uncertain whether the court clerk and
judge would be asked to enforce the new
abortion law basically they were saying
that they had no idea whether
anti-abortion activists who had waited
over 40 years for this moment would not
necessarily seek to enforce the law
immediately this by the way is part of
the court's probably unfairly named
shadow docket in other words this isn't
a full appeal to the supreme court it's
an emergency application that often
these things are decided just by not
taking them up it's actually
fairly rare to get a decision from the
majority when they say that they're not
going to grant
injunctive relief and what they do in
this particular case is they basically
say that while the law is probably
unconstitutional there are some
procedural quirks that are not going to
allow them to get to these questions
right now and they just don't see the
need to grant injunctive emergency
relief and here is the entirety of the
supreme court's decision it's about 500
words from this unsigned five
conservative justice majority quote the
application for injunctive relief or in
the alternative to vacate the stays of
the district court proceedings presented
to justice toledo and by him referred to
the court is denied to prevail in an
application for a stay or an injunction
an applicant must carry the burden of
making a strong showing that it is
likely to succeed on the merits and that
it will be irreparably injured absent a
stay that the balance of the equities
favors it and that his stay is
consistent with a public interest so far
so good that's completely normal that is
the standard for a temporary restraining
order in an emergency context like this
the applicants now before us have raised
serious questions regarding the
constitutionality of the texas law at
issue yeah no kidding but their
application also presents complex and
novel antecedent procedural questions on
which they have not carried their burden
for example federal courts enjoy the
power to enjoin individuals tasked with
enforcing laws not the laws themselves
and it is unclear whether the name
defendants in this lawsuit can or will
seek to enforce the texas law against
the applicants in a manner that might
permit our intervention the state has
represented that neither it nor its
executive employees possess the
authority to enforce the texas law
either directly or indirectly nor is it
clear whether under existing precedent
the court can issue an injunction
against state judges asked to decide a
lawsuit under texas law finally the sole
private citizen responded before us has
filed an affidavit stating that he has
no present intention to enforce the law
in light of such issues we cannot say
that applicants have met their burden to
prevail in injunction or stay
application in reaching this conclusion
we stress that we do not purport to
resolve definitively any jurisdictional
or substantive claim in the applicant's
lawsuit in particular this order is not
based on any conclusion about the
constitutionality of texas's law and in
no way limits other procedurally proper
challenges to texas's law including in
texas state courts this decision raises
so many questions first can plaintiffs
actually sue the court clerk and judge
in this kind of situation justice
breyer's dissent suggested the answer
would certainly be yes since you can't
have a right without a remedy to enforce
it quote it should prove possible to
apply procedures adequate to that task
here perhaps by printing lawsuits
against a subset of delegates say those
particularly likely to exercise the
delegated powers or perhaps by
permitting lawsuits against officials
whose actions are necessary to implement
the statute's enforcement powers and
that's also the gist of district court
judge pittman's order on august 25th
quote while empowering private enforcers
sb-8 limits the defenses available to
defendants and subjects them to a
fee-shifting regime skewed in favor of
claimants for example defendants and
sp-8 enforcement actions are prohibited
from raising certain defenses enumerated
under sb-8 including they believe the
law was unconstitutional that they
relied on a court decision later
overruled that was in place at the time
of the acts underlying the suit or that
the patient consented to the abortion
section 5 vesp8 requires state judges to
weigh the undue burden anew in every
case as part of an affirmative defense
in line with sb 8's new strictures
regarding construction and severability
of claims judge pittman noted that sba
doesn't leave state officials with
nothing to do instead the law as it is
now codified empowers state agencies to
bring administrative and civil
enforcement actions against medical
professionals who participate in
abortions that violate the six-week ban
based on their state-issued licenses and
under the state medical practice act for
examples the state medical board must
initiate investigations in disciplinary
action against as well as refuse to
issue or renew licenses to licensed
physicians who violate the provision of
sb-8 the state nursing and pharmacy
boards and health and human services
divisions also perform similar
administrative functions judge pittman's
point was that if providers were not
able to perform abortions they face
private enforcement actions as well as
professional disciplinary sanctions
which are enforced by the state and i'll
note parenthetically that when you
involve the judicial system in enforcing
things in other contexts that clearly
involves state action for example the
limits of defamation law fall under the
first amendment because it's the court
that is enforcing defamation judgments
and same with the court's inherent
contempt authority often that runs right
up against the first amendment because
it's the judge who is doing something in
court that is a state action in this
case both the fifth circuit and the
supreme court bent over backwards to
make sure that this law would go into
effect which is probably going to cause
chaos within texas because people just
don't know what's going to happen and
what the status of the law is and we
know that this is beyond the pale
because chief justice roberts wrote in
his dissent that if nothing else that
the court should have enjoined the law
from going into effect so that there was
proper time for uh the case to wind its
way through the fifth circuit and
supreme court on actual merits decisions
that was not completely unusual for the
supreme court to grant an emergency stay
which prevents the law's enforcement
until the case makes its way through the
courts and for a party to prevail they
have to show that there would be
irreparable harm and that they would be
likely to prevail on the merits in a
case like this there would presumably be
irreparable harm people who wanted
abortions but were unable to get them in
a party making that argument would be
extremely likely to succeed on the
merits since a six-week ban on abortion
goes directly against roe and casey but
the supreme court's majority claim that
these providers failed to make a strong
showing that their legal arguments would
be likely to succeed on the marriage
which is basically telegraphing that
the supreme court will when given the
chance over rule roe versus wade right
out in the open when they have the
opportunity but here in this particular
case they're splitting the baby because
the majority specifically states that
the law raises real constitutional
questions but punts because of the crazy
cockamamie procedure that the texas
legislature created this is completely
nuts one would think that if you
recognize the clear unconstitutionality
based on the court's current
jurisprudence casey is still technically
good law then it would only doubly mean
that you should enjoy this law if they
have this crazy rube goldberg machine
built into this law not letting them get
a free pass because of the machinations
that they've created here and in her
dissent justice sonia sotomayar did not
mince words about this move quote the
court has rewarded the state's efforts
to delay federal court review of a
plainly unconstitutional statute enacted
in disregard of the court's precedence
through procedural entanglements of the
state's own creation the court should
not be so content to ignore its
constitutional obligations to protect
not only the rights of women but also
the sanctity of its precedence and the
rule of law chief justice roberts also
dissented along the same lines quote the
statutory scheme before the court is not
only unusual but unprecedented the
legislature has imposed a prohibition on
abortions after roughly six weeks and
then essentially delegated enforcement
of that prohibition to the populace at
large the desired consequence appears to
be to insulate the state from
responsibility for implementing and
enforcing the regulatory regime justice
breyer disagreed with the majority's
view that his hands were procedurally
tied quote texas law delegates to
private individuals the power to prevent
a woman from obtaining an abortion
during the first stage of pregnancy but
a woman has a federal constitutional
right to obtain abortion during that
first stage and justice kagan's dissent
called out her colleagues for abusing
the shadow daca yet the majority has
acted without any guidance from the
court of appeals which is right now
considering the same issues it has
reviewed only the most cursory party
submissions and then only hastily and it
barely bothers to explain his conclusion
that the challenge to an obviously
unconstitutional abortion regulation
backed by a wholly unprecedented
enforcement scheme is unlikely to
prevail in all these ways the majority's
decision is emblematic of too much of
this court shadow docket decision making
which every day becomes more unreason
inconsistent and impossible to defend so
regardless of where you stand on the
political issue of abortion this is just
bad law making and bad decision making
it's bad for the rule of law the way
that the court went about this allowing
the fifth circuit to undo the
preliminary injunction that the district
court put in place has created massive
uncertainty for no reason the supreme
court will probably
overrule roe vs wade in the next term
why go about this half-hearted measure
to do it on the shadow docket
ahead of time it also leaves open all
kinds of new crazy laws it telegraphs to
every state in the country that they can
get around constitutional issues and
constitutional review by simply using
the same private bounty hunter
enforcement mechanism and it could go
both ways imagine if a state passed a
law that said
if you ate or bet someone exercising
their freedom of religion then you're
subject to a ten thousand dollar fine
and you have to pay the other side's
attorney's fees or on the other side of
the political spectrum if you ate or bet
someone buying a firearm and exercising
their second amendment rights uh then
you are subject to tens of thousands of
dollars in fines and uh you have to pay
the other side's attorney's fees because
only private individuals are going to
enforce this anti-handgun measure but in
reality none of that's going to happen
because this was an ad hoc decision with
one outcome in mind if a similar law
comes up in a different context the
supreme court will just simply say that
it's different for some ad hoc reason
and it will uh enjoin those laws from
going into effect again this isn't
necessarily about the political issue of
abortion it's about trying to uphold
consistency with the law and the rule of
law itself this is terrible for all
kinds of jurisprudential reasons though
as an aside remember that this is only
with respect to whether the right to an
abortion or the right to choose is
enshrined within the constitution itself
there are always legislative remedies
here congress could pass a law that
grants exactly the same rights
as conferred by roe versus wade or
planned parenthood versus casey of
course a law can always be undone but of
course it's harder to undo a law once
it's been passed and obviously there are
procedural issues with the filibuster
that make it unlikely that the bare
democratic majority in the house and the
senate would be able to pass such a law
but that is always an option here now
the headline roe versus way is dead
might be a slight exaggeration because
technically planned parenthood versus
casey is still the law of the land but
the law in texas has been changed and
roe vs wade if not dead is on life
support and it looks like it's only a
matter of time until the current makeup
of the supreme court finishes the job
that they started on wednesday though
the justice department has now filed a
lawsuit against the state of texas but
it probably won't succeed in any
meaningful way in the complaint the doj
argues that the states have no right to
quote impede burden or in any manner
control the operations of the
constitutional laws enacted by congress
to carry into effect the powers vested
in the national government a state law
is invalid if it quote stands as an
obstacle to the accomplishment and
execution of the full purposes and
objectives of congress or if it directly
regulates quote the activities of the
federal government the u.s has also sued
to assert other federal interests that
they claim sb-8 unconstitutionally
impairs the statute is alleged to have
unconstitutionally restricted the labor
department's job corps program the
defense department's tricare health
program the office of refugee settlement
the bureau of prisons the centers of
medicare and medicaid services and the
office of personnel management and
that's not surprising because as we
talked about sba bans nearly all
abortions in the state after six weeks
of pregnancy which is in direct conflict
with planned parenthood versus casey but
the problem here is that planned
parenthood versus casey probably won't
be the law next term when the supreme
court takes up one of several abortion
related cases and as we talked about
cases that are decided on the shadow
docket related to emergency petitions
don't carry any presidential value but
it does telegraph what the various
justices are willing to do and in what
context and this is a pretty clear
signal that they're going to overrule
planned parenthood versus casey and roe
vs wade when it comes up on the official
docket in next term and regarding the
bounty hunter provisions the doj asserts
that enforcement by private citizens
makes them state actors but again here
the fifth circuit has already ruled on
that particular argument and the supreme
court dismissed the argument on the
shadow docket so it's extremely unlikely
that the doj is going to get a second
bite at the apple on that particular
issue especially when the fifth circuit
has already weighed in and the supreme
court has approved of that decision and
speaking of that court of appeals the
fifth circuit finally wrote an opinion
to explain its decision in whole women's
health this is actually unrelated to the
new doj lawsuit but according to the
fifth circuit sb-8 emphatically
precludes enforcement by any state local
or agency officials the defendant
officials thus lack any enforcement
connection to sp-8 and are not amenable
to suit under ex-party versus young
therefore the fifth circuit opines that
the plaintiffs don't have any claim
quote against the state licensing
officials namely the executive directors
of the texas medical board texas nursing
board or the texas board of pharmacy or
the state health and human services
commissioner the court says it's mindful
that sba violates people's
constitutional rights but that women
can't sue at this particular time and
that they might be able to sue in the
future here's that language we are
mindful that sb8 applies to
pre-viability abortions which may raise
serious questions regarding the
constitutionality of the texas law the
citation but also see noting the court's
order in no way limits other
procedurally proper challenges to the
texas law including in texas state
courts so effectively the fifth circuit
is saying that the only way to challenge
this law is to wait for a person to sue
under the bounty hunter provision and
then raise the constitutionality of sb-8
as a defense to liability and the fifth
circuit was certainly not going to waste
the decision of the supreme court
stating quote we are also mindful of the
real world effects while courts resolve
these vexing procedural questions but we
point out as did the supreme court the
potential sba defendants will be able to
raise defenses before state courts that
are bound to enforce the constitution so
unfortunately there's going to be a ton
of confusion while we wait for someone
to try to enforce the bounty hunter
provisions at which time the defendant
will then try to claim that sba was
unconstitutional from the get-go in
which case we'll be right back in front
of the courts making all of these same
arguments again so do you need to vent
about the court's decisions or maybe
call your congressperson get them to
pass a legislative solution well if you
don't throw your cell phone out the
window in frustration you can actually
save a ton of money on that call with
ting mobile today's sponsor in fact i
personally switched to t-mobile and
saved literally hundreds of dollars a
month i'm not kidding why well because
of this yes that is a real cell phone
bill that i got with my previous
provider and that's why i personally
switched to ting and ting mobile has
three brand new plans to make sure that
that never happens again all of ting's
plans have unlimited talk and text
starting at just 10 per month so you can
use the flex plan and only pay for what
you use which is especially great if
you're around wi-fi all day or choose a
set of 12 gigabytes of data for 35 or
get full unlimited for just 45 a month
switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep your same phone
number and pretty much use any phone the
service is great too because ting
partners with several massive networks
probably the very same one that you're
using right now but at a huge discount
they literally use the exact same
infrastructure now actually i can't tell
you which ones because i always respect
contracts but let's just say that my
service hasn't changed at all except for
getting much much cheaper you can sign
up for ting's flex plan that lets you
just pay for what you use now they just
give you the possibility of unlimited
versions as well so if you want
unlimited you can go absolutely crazy
it's incredibly easy to transfer service
just by simply ordering a ting sim card
popping it in and setting it up no phone
calls required it's like magic but if
you do want to talk to ting you can call
them up and immediately talk to a real
human being or talk to a real human on
chat or discord i used to be on the
phone for hours with my last provider
but never with ting now if you'd like to
give ting a try legal eagles will get a
25 service credit that could cover two
months of service all you have to do is
click on the link below and give it a
try you can click on the link that's on
screen or in the description you'll get
a free 25 service credit and save a ton
on your mobile phone bill so just click
on the link that's on screen plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel and while you're there
check out this playlist with all of my
real law reviews covering the most
important legal issues of the day so
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court